- [Instructor] So I have a
rectangle drawn right over here.
And my goal is to split this rectangle up
into smaller, equal squares.
And the way that I'm going to do that
is by first dividing this
rectangle into two rows,
and I should say two equal rows.
And then I'm going to
divide this rectangle
into five equal columns.
Now, I know some of you are saying,
"What is a row and what is a column?"
So a row, at least my
brain thinks about it
as a part of the rectangle that
is going from left to right.
One way to think about it,
if I had a bunch of, let's say
that these are apples here.
And if I wanted to think about dividing
these apples into rows,
I would say that this is the first row.
This is a second row.
And that this is a third row.
If I were to think in terms of columns,
I tend to think of
columns as going up down.
And so the columns, this
would be one column.
This would be another column.
This would be a third column,
and this would be a fourth column.
So now that we understand
what rows and columns are,
let's first think about,
maybe pause this video and
think about how would you divide
this rectangle into two rows.
Well, the way that I would tackle it is,
I would draw a line that
goes from left to right,
and there you have it.
I now have the rectangle
split into one row
and now a second row.
Now pause the video
and you could draw this
if you have a pencil and paper with you,
or you could just think
about what I should do.
How would I now divide this
rectangle into five columns?
Well, what I could do
is make a bunch of lines
that go from top to bottom.
So that's one column there.
This is a second column.
This is a third column.
This is a fourth column
and a fifth column.
So there you have it.
I have two rows, one row, two rows,
and I have five columns.
One, two, three, four, five.
Now what's interesting is
when I split the rectangle
in this way into two
rows and five columns,
how many equal size squares did I create?
Well, I've created one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10 equal squares.
And that makes sense
because each row has five.
I have one, two, three, four, five.
One, two, three, four, five.
And five plus five is equal to 10.
Another way to think about
it is each column has two,
one, two, one, two, one,
two, one two, one, two.
And two plus two is four,
plus two is six, plus two
is eight, plus two is 10.
So that's what splitting
the rectangle into two rows
and five columns gets me,
it splits it into 10 sections.